Sie berichten ja ja immer mal wieder über die riesige bedrohung die von asteroiden ausgeht denn auf den punkt gebracht sind wir ihnen
genau wie das restliche leben auf der erde einfach nur schutzlos ausgeliefert in diesem zusammenhang waren
forschungsteams weltweit vor den asteroiden 20 10 11 12
apophis und auch bei
denen die nasa zum gefährlichsten aller bekannten asteroiden
zählt was man alles zu diesen riesen brocken wissen sollte wie hoch die bedrohung wirklich ist und ob die
geplante abwehrraketen der nasa tatsächlich das potenzial hat das leben auf der erde zu schützen
jetzt in klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Vielen dank für diesen themen vorschlag an die whatsapp
community so langsam dämmert es der ganzen menschheit die erde ist ständig bedroht von kollisionen mit erdnahen asteroiden
und wird auf dauer von einem riesigen brocken getroffen werden
garantiert viele objekte sind klein und verglühen in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es bemerken dass ein himmelskörper in die atmosphäre
eindringt und explodiert oder einschlägt kommt allerdings öfter vor als wir denken so wie es eventuell auch mit apophis
passieren könnte den affen kennen wir seit dem jahr 2005 einen 300 meter
klumpen der nach dem ägyptischen gott der finsternis und das chaos benannt ist im jahr 2029
soll er die erde um nur knapp 30.000 kilometer verfehlen er fliegt also unter den geostationären satelliten durch so nah
dass wir ihn vielleicht sogar mit bloßem auge erkennen können so spekulieren manche ein paar jahre später nämlich
2095 volk 20 10 11 12 mit einem durchmesser von etwa zehn metern
116 so hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass er auf der erde einschlagen wird doch wirklich sorgen machen müssen wir uns derzeit nicht denn bei seiner größe ist
wirklich kein großer schaden zu erwarten in
900 jahren dann steht ein gigantischer asteroid auf dem plan der az 29 0 75 19 50 dpa
mit einem durchmesser von einem kilometer
forschungsteams haben die wahrscheinlichkeit dass auf der erde einschlägt mit 1 zu
300 berechnet und das ist gar nicht gut aber schon bald kommt uns wenn er nach einschätzung der nase einer der
gefährlichsten hast so ihnen überhaupt am 25 september
2001 135 könnte er der erde tatsächlich
gefährlich nahe kommen und das hätte mit einem durchmesser von 500 metern und einem gewicht von
87 millionen tonnen fatale folgen bei einem aufprall würde er nach berechnungen der nasa wohl eine energie von
88.000 atombomben freisetzen das entspricht einer kinetische energie von
1200 megatonnen uns bleiben also noch 100 jahre um gegenmaßnahmen für diesen möglichen
asteroideneinschlag zu erarbeiten und genau daran tüfteln die behörde namens planetary die fans team der nasa vor kurzem
gegründet mit hochdruck stichwort hemmer
steht für high
Pavarotti geschen mission for emergency response wege einen neun meter
langes und knapp neun tonnen schweres raumschiff das mit einer delta 4
heavy in den weltraum gebracht werden soll es könnte nicht nur als transportmittel für eine atombombe dienen sondern auch als rammbock
beispielsweise für benni denn ein kleiner schubser könnte den asteroiden zu einer kursänderung
bringen und selbst wenn dieser erst einmal nur minimal wäre könnte er den kurs mit einer gewissen vorlaufzeit im laufe der zeit immer weiter
verschieben doch erst einmal müsste das raumschiff
überhaupt gebaut werden die mission und die flugzeit geplant werden und je mehr zeit vergeht umso schwieriger
gestaltet sich dieser plan zehn jahre vor dem errechneten einschlag von benny bräuchte mal schon bis zu
53 hemmers um sein kurs zu ändern oder aber man agiert doch mit einer atombombe gegen ihn wobei es hierbei auch wieder einige riesen gibt
risiken
könnte in mehrere teile aufgespalten werden die dann weiterhin kurs auf die erde nehmen ihr könnt euch alle ausmalen
was bei einem asteroideneinschlag auf der erde passieren könnte hollywood filme dazu gibt es ja genug
fliegende trümmer tsunami wellen und schlimme erdbeben etwa
könnten wirklich ein großteil des lebens auf der erde auslöschen doch viel mehr sorgen machen sich
forschungsteams um die kleineren objekte denn von ihnen sind geschätzt nur ein prozent bekannt ganz im gegensatz zu den gigantischen gesteinsbrocken aus dem all
die nasa und die anderen weltraumagenturen auf dem schirm haben das hat beispielsweise
auch der überraschende einschlag des asteroiden in der nähe des ural gebirges chelyabinsk
im jahr 2013 gezeigt er hatte einen durchmesser von 20 metern und wog etwa
16.000 tonnen doch rund
1500 menschen wurden verletzt und 700 gebäude wurden beschädigt fest steht jedenfalls hätte man dies
vorausgesehen hätte man schlimmeres ganz einfach verhindern können dass bloße öffnen der gebäude fenster
hätte den großteil der schäden vermeiden können und um genau das schon frühzeitig voraus zu
sagen nämlich wie viele hast du jeden wann genau der erde nahe kommen könnten müsste der komplette nachthimmel
regelmäßig abgescannt werden erst im juni diesen jahres hat die nasa
ein strategiepapier zu asteroiden abwehr vorgelegt demnach müssen dringend möglichkeiten entwickelt werden mit denen die flugbahnen der
gesteinsbrocken
beeinflusst werden können auch hier betont die nasa noch einmal dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit für einen schlimmen einschlag gering ist doch die folgen umso katastrophaler und wir dürfen nicht vergessen
jedes jahr gibt es rund zwei asteroiden einschläge von denen wir allerdings kaum etwas mitbekommen weil sie meistens in
unbewohntem gebiet
einschlagen bis 2020 sollen jetzt alle erdnahen asteroiden die größer sind als 140 meter entdeckt
zuverlässig entdeckt werden können experten und expertinnen plädieren immer wieder für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines koordinierten
frühwarnsystem auch in europa macht man sich gedanken dazu die esa plant im kommenden jahr ein neues teleskop auf sie zielt
aufzubauen um den nachthimmel nach objekten abzusuchen ein solches teleskop würde das innerhalb von
maximal vier nächten schaffen um den himmel in einer nacht ab zu scannen bräuchte es drei bis vier solcher
teleskop wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
dann umgeht er die kaputte abo box er auf you tube und verpasst kein video mehr
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr mehr von mir noch vor allen andern vom neuesten video ich schicke euch dann vorher eine nachricht und zwar täglich
und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür
da klicken aber nicht die
können auch die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit
achtung darauf auch dann klicken die erde in die knapp einem großen asteroiden einschlag bis dann
bleibt dran